hello and welcome to this video this is
a video in the middle game strategy
serious yeah it also could have been
part of chess Giants which is also as
serious on my channel which is not
garage not has been updated for quite a
while but I think it's also probably
situated in middle game strategy I'm
going to show you a complete game here
played by a keyboard Stein one of my
favorite classical players this game is
from 1928 which means at the time
Rubenstein's Korea was already yeah
basically over and he played a little
bit after that but not much and his
active chess playing was was ended by
World War two his best times were in the
in the years 2000 2000 F 19 1911 in 1912
when he was a very very strong and with
some probability even a bit stronger
than then world champion last year but
he never got a World Championship match
ok we don't want to make this a history
lesson but look at a game his opponent
is nimzowitsch so what opening do we get
yep the nimzo-indian so a very nice duel
here yeah Rubinstein of course is the
inventor of the move for e3 the
Rubinstein variation one of many
Rubinstein was a fantastic opening yeah
he was very inventive in the opening he
really got made popular many nights
Rubinstein variation in the friends
French defense here in the nihms oh
there's a Rubinstein in the for night
since its its countless in this game
however he played Queen c2 but we see
that pretty shortly his mixing idea so
it's um it's some kind of a
a mix between the Rubinstein and the
classical Quincy to youngnam's ovitch
plays d6 this is not the most popular
move nowadays and it also wasn't popular
back then but we really have to see that
this was completely new territory at the
time you have to keep in mind that for
example we are talking about 1920 ATM in
1927 just one year before that there was
the World Championship match between 11
and kappa blanka and in that match they
played the Queen's Gambit in about 30
games and not once the news oh yes so we
are talking about completely new
territory
yeah d6 this is not a bad move it's just
a little bit unpopular the way news of
it she plays it however it's not that
great
u3 is played not necessary white also
could have played with this bishop
outside of the pawn chain but Rubenstein
has a different idea we'll see quickly
what it is a c5 and Bishop d3 96 and a G
- I actually don't like names of which
some set up here because the problem is
if you are a black in the new zone you
are very much yeah not always but almost
all the time giving up that Bishop on c3
and you want some kind of compensation
for giving up the bishop
one compensation can be structure a
double pole another compensation can be
time and here after d5 news of each is
taking this completely voluntarily yeah
he could have played 97 there wasn't a
huge huge issue with that move me let's
say 97 and yeah now what at least we'll
have to spend a move on a3
yeah not a big deal but at least it's a
temple he's some doing yes some
completely as I said voluntarily yeah
Queen um c3 was played yeah
Rubinstein doesn't want a double pawn it
wouldn't have been that terrible but
it's not necessary really
and Knight takes is just bad on account
of night before we don't want to give
like that Bishop and yeah with gain of
time and trade of a piece that's not a
good idea
so Quincy Israel's played 97 Manchester
how nimzowitsch treated this kind of
position note that in this position
going to 85 as it is sometimes an idea
in the nimzo-indian to play against the
Seahawk home here is just a bad idea
because the pawn on c4 can always be
safely protected by b3 there is no
double pawn yeah if that would be if we
look at this for example this does make
quite a bit of more sense because this
cannot be supported by a pawn
so after three takes 97's played um
Queen c2 my Rubinstein he makes sure
that he was not happening what about the
move pawn to e4 was that a good move yes
it was a good move not a bad move at all
completing this pawn chain in the center
why does a little bit better here
because of his space and the two bishops
he either had an entirely different set
up in mind Rubenstein's idea is to play
without the default and we will see
someone later what consequence this has
Queen c2 looking at those squares yeah
preventing efore preventing Bishop f5
things like that news of which castles
he just sticks with his plan of setting
up sound solid position with them yeah
as I say good Bishop on the light square
against dark square
however it's important to understand
that this is not entirely satisfactory
for black he still suffers from a space
disadvantage and has no concrete counter
play instead of counseling he had ideas
and I think modern player would
definitely consider that he had ideas to
play things like b5 you had to get
active them and maybe open a line yeah
some some kind of counter play
yeah modern player wouldn't really like
to sit there without counter play but
back then or at different times castles
castles in 96 yeah the thing is black
doesn't really have a very concrete plan
with that with that move 93 this is a
good move again it looks at those two
squares so black will not be able to
ever push the e pawn forward it controls
some whiter squares from g3 Ruki 8 and
now a very very good strategic move the
tell-tale sign of a good strategic
player what did he play now imp let the
move f3 that looks like very easy that
looks very slow in this move but it's a
very good strategic move it absolutely
make sure that if is never happening it
takes away a square G form for blacks
pieces and it just gives black gives
white a couple of more options yeah the
Queen might come over look f2 yeah it's
slow but it this has very high quality
this move it does some things and it
doesn't spoil anything and this is often
the way those strategic games go it's
just very slowish and improving the
position Bishop d7 is played again
nimzowitsch is not going for any
anything quick account like I want to
play Bishop d2 he 6 so he prepares b5
uh-huh
is it a good idea now for white to play
the move a4
and yeah he could have done that it's
not necessary but it is a move a for was
interesting how would it continue
probably be five I mean black wants to
do something and after b5 what can take
and take here it's not not a bad idea to
do that I mean white opens up the
position he's got possible before and
only move like let's say it's a ruby
trades and ninety-five something that 94
comes into consideration this is not bad
for white at all however this is not a
very strategically minded continuation
it's more like something concrete and
Rubinstein felt that he rather wants a
slowish better where he can improve
slowly this is quite often the right
recipe if you have more space and the
bishop pair to Beckett you want to play
very slowly and open up the position for
the bishops in exactly the right way
it's not a good idea to rush things
just keep the position as is and slowly
go forward
how will wide open up the position we
would see shortly note that he never
goes before yeah if white plays d4 then
he just giving up this square and all of
a sudden black has got some kind of
activity okay he went aged three a very
very slow move but it has an idea we
will see very shortly what it is don't
want to want to spoil it b5 b3
yeah we support this pawn on c4 and
Queen b6 yeah what is Rubenstein's next
move there are many many slow improving
moves Bishop c3 look a b1 anticipating
the capture what did what did he do he
played the most King edge too
yeah why not you have all the time there
and it's absolutely helping a little bit
to get the King away to age - it's just
a little bit safer there yeah it's it's
away from possible things on that
diagonal even though this diagonal is
very closed but we have all the time in
the world
also if you imagine at some point if
pawns advance then again the King is
better on h2 because there might be Ruby
g1 things like that it's just a slow
little improving move like when a five
and now Rubinstein when Ruby one yeah
move that I've mentioned earlier putting
it on the B file anticipating that black
might open the position on that part of
the board yeah any alternatives an
interesting alternative was the mid a
for the idea is that white absolutely
does not mind from black to block with
before after before we get a position
that is very similar to the game
actually can compare that easily
black will probably instead take and
play this position here we have an
interesting situation the B file is open
and both bishops take a look take a look
at those pawns however the thing that
white is better because it can combine
play on the Kings side with the a pawn
hanging on a5 a4 was a valid alternative
route b1 whoever is also good there's
absolutely nothing wrong with Rubinstein
smooth yeah what did news Oh which play
now he really went for before this is
kind of um yeah following his principle
that a pawn chain should be attacked at
the base which means attack attack it on
or b3 the thing is that's all nice and
good but once you attack it white is
just
okay whatever you can attack me all day
long it doesn't really matter that much
the problem is still like has little
counter play and now White's pawn break
is really coming into effect he goes for
an f4
that was the idea all along when he
delayed or not delayed he even never
played it when he em didn't go for a
three or four the whole time he wanted
to play f4 in this kind of situation
gaining space but not allowing black to
take on f4 and establishing a piece
outpost on e5 let's think about this a
little bit if white display it with some
kind of e for ya in any given moment if
white plays f4 there will be an outpost
on e5 for black let's just say this
looks very clumsy but just for the
general idea black takes and now in this
situation or immediately 95 there's a
big outpost on d8 this is a weak Square
and it can be a good outpost for a rook
or for the knight being repositioned to
e5 in this position the white bishop is
also looked looking pretty pretty stupid
doesn't do anything this is absolutely
not acceptable for white we don't want
this kind of structure the only possible
structure that is kind of yeah desirable
after Gong Evo would be with the other
night moving g3 and then f4 so that
after he takes F you can recapture with
the pawn and keeping this structure yeah
keeping this sound so that there's no II
five square but this is very very very
very very long-winded so why not skip a
four all together and play f4 now if
black now captures which is what he did
then white
we kept us with the porn and we know
that we have gained space while not
giving up any central square efore is
very safely controlled 'if v is
controlled by the pawn and this Bishop
is an excellent piece it's not in any
way hampered by an e4 pawn so this kind
of advance is just stronger than
anything with E 4 and then some
elaborate G 3 F 4 it's a very
interesting way to play and and I said
White has gained lots of space and this
can even be um increased further f4 f5
if you want
as I said news which took on f4 he also
could have played a four yeah not
capturing on therefore it's a very
interesting question what would have
happened them the Rubinstein definitely
had the option of playing f5 gaining
more space and kicking this Knight back
from here he easily could have improved
further yeah the next or not the next
step but one very likely next step would
be to prepare the advance g4 g5 yeah
creating this avalanche on the on the
kingside gaining even more space the big
squeeze however here there also is an
alternative that is very interesting
wide also and has the idea to capture on
e5 this is entirely different
if black now recaptures and okay okay he
will yeah so let's let's check Ruby if I
have for example what happens after you
get five white now has the opportunity
to sacrifice the exchange M takes takes
rook F 1 this gives white excellent
really excellent compensation for the
exchange and very good attacking chances
f6 is a weakness that sometimes can
be attacked very effectively by the
night
not right now ana h5 is protected but
it's in the position it's part of the
position and white will certainly yeah
and put the black King in danger that's
a very very dangerous concentration
continuation after 90 85 the sacrifice
is probably even stronger yeah something
like 90 XD three can be answered by and
further increasing the pressure that
stead looks really really funky but
after G takes nine th five whites attack
is probably impossible to resist it's
just very very strong so this was an
interesting possibility that didn't
happen because nimzowitsch took on f4
right away not sure maybe he was afraid
of this possibility that that sacrifice
on f6 but also can be that he just
wanted to have a clearer structure then
opened the ephah for his rook even
though we have to take note that this is
not really a file that black is somehow
controlling all the squares are guarded
by white pieces so after he takes a form
Knight f3 it was played news which was
dropping back and he plays the whole
game with a very passive mindset not not
really doing anything this is really
sometimes
this happened to him quite a bit in when
he played his own opening the
nimzo-indian and in some games when he
was experimenting with different setups
by modern standards he played it to to
passively in many occasions night of 8
yeah now now we seem a very a very
instructive moment White's position is
quite obviously better
he's got more space better pieces but
still it's not quite clear how we're
going to do how we're going to get
something very very serious out of that
very often the question to ask is are
all pieces deployed in the most
effective way and if we ask that
question here for white we will get an
answer
it all looks fine but what about the
rooks and what about the bishop on d2
it's not so clear what the rooks can do
yeah sometimes like rook F 3 possible
rook g3 can come to mind but that it's
not really something we can put into
action very quickly very clearly the
bishop on d2 is wrong it looks at F 4
and B form
yeah a black pawn and a white pawn and
well that's not good
sold bishop c1 this is a strong move the
bishop gets really ployed to the long
diagonal Queen d8 was played and now
Queen F - what about Bishop b2 that a
good move that was the idea thing is
always think about short move tactics
sometimes short move tactics can spoil
the best strategic effort if you
overlook a simple tactic Queen d8 yeah
it's very important whenever the
opponent makes a move to think a bit
about his motivation for them
why did black play queen d8 of course
sometimes they're really shuffled
without any idea but there might be an
idea with Queen d8 and there is an idea
the differences between the Queen and e8
and e9 b6 that it is ready to jump out
there and if we go Bishop b2 black hands
just quite annoying possibility after
takes Queen and check and hinge e1 and
e3 this is looking kind of tricky yeah
black queen has invaded um the position
is actually not that terrible for what
but it's really nothing that we want to
consider because we have total control
if we play just one prophylactic move
yeah here look we have three is not that
not that bad and black captures and five
leads to some very serious attack yeah
like this and this but that's really not
something that we need to look at if we
just play Queen f2 we keep all the
advantages in the position and can
continue to build up a form we should be
to now of course Nagi 6 yes whoa he
dropped back to evade no back to g6 that
doesn't look great but what exactly did
black have instead rook e1 now it's not
quite clear that that was necessary
really
yeah maybe he didn't want to he just
wanted to move the rook away from the
befoul possibly preparing bishop b1
covering a two and he didn't want to go
look e one maybe because of trades want
to keep things on the board but well
what has time it's not very time
critical and takes takes rook a7 and now
we went to e1 yeah so white probably um
gave up a tempo here but it's not a big
deal news of H captured which is a
decent idea and you want to trade pieces
when you are
suffering from a space disadvantage
neither fate was played yeah now we come
to a very nice moment in this game here
what has a couple of good-looking moves
yeah he has some slow improving moves
and he has some direct ideas
my first instinct in this position
probably would be to play something like
Bishop to be one to just totally make
sure that there's never okay to
happening completely taking away
anything on the Queen side and then
maybe trying to slowly improve on the
Kings side there are a couple of ways to
do that for example white can think of
moving that night and then go for a g4
advance g4 not back to g3 g5 yeah use
the pawns and pieces combined yeah we
have to take note of how strong those
bishops are just a fantastic position
there is however an even stronger
solution and one that shows some how
strong a player Rubinstein was he now
went for transformation of advantages he
transforms his bishop a advantage to
something concrete by capturing on f6
this looks like a strange move at first
sight but if you look into it a little
bit deeper you would see how strong this
is and it is even stronger than some
slowish maneuvering because this
transformation of advantages it
transforms something that is somewhat
non concrete yes the payoff bishops and
space advance to something concrete
because white is getting something clear
that he can attack you'll see what it is
and Queen takes 94 and now we see efore
is a saree night only for attacks the d6
pawn black in order to keep the pawn
protected
and only has one option has to go to age
six yeah you cannot go here and because
of the discovered attack so Queen had to
go to age six and now the key move f5
and this is what Rubinstein had seen
beforehand with f5
he's completely paralyzing blacks pieces
the knight cannot ever go to g6e sixes
totally totally under wraps and the idea
is pretty straightforward white wants to
try to play Queen g3 or Queen to f4 on
the right circumstances and attack the
d6 pawn which is very very difficult to
keep White's position is really clearly
clearly better nimzowitsch went through
k3 attacking the b3 pawn and just back
to be one asking black okay what are you
doing
note how well White's pieces are
coordinated the black Queen has very
little that it can do it can only go to
h5 in this position just one Square and
black in general is totally limited with
this with his pieces if he plays
something let's say like a bishop seed
intending 97 then f6 is very strong as
well we attack d6 now and we managed to
break through on the Kings side a big
problem and this is what what names of
idjit he defended d6 from the side so
that f6 now wouldn't be an attack on
their pawn now black has 96 and possibly
95 very important don't allow
possibilities like that white is in
total control and wants to improve his
position first what he played is much
stronger he played the strong space
gaining move
for note that wide by let's say simple
standard has a bad bishop yeah it's a
light square bishop all-white spawns on
light squares this is however completely
irrelevant because we have this much
space Bishop on d3 is of course much
much stronger than the one on D seven
who is yeah sitting on a light square
with blacks pawns on dark squares this
is not relevant at all they are far more
concrete consideration cm wide effect
here of the g4 has a very very direct
threat if like is playing something
ignorant then g5 and who in here Bishop
e2 and it is trapped it's just gone so
this thread is something that black has
to attend to and he went and f6 had to
do that yeah let's see how can we
continue here white has a very nice
control but how to do it he found a very
nice way to to play this queen g3 was a
possibility directly looking at the six
but as mentioned white really has lots
of time there is no need to rush things
King g3 looking at age for looking at f4
covering covering some squares Bishop c8
and now back to e1 why does looking for
the decisive blow on the if our black
went Bishop to b7 yeah that doesn't
really help but it is it is a bad
position and stays one what about 97
instead a very good move
yeah the thing is that white probably
can just take on d6 after up t6 and
rupee a check check came here Ruby c8
black
has this 95 idea but the problem is that
it's not really threatening that much
what can I think of checking and taking
one c5 yeah
Quincey oneness account to play with
it's probably not enough this is what
nimzowitsch had seen and he decided
against this instead when Bishop d7
Queen e2 looking at the e-file again
ideally coming to here note that with
the King on g3 those counter Pleiades by
the black queen are prevented black weed
has no square it's a really nice
squeezing game 97 and again there's a
little tactic and Bush attacking this
okay black has to take check check an ID
evade only move and now Ruby seven white
is entering on the e-file his rents
Queen f7 and then Queen f8 maid and note
blacks Queen has no meaningful check
yeah Queen III check but this is really
not doing anything good would be typical
computer move yeah news of each stride
and g6 check check and King back and
Ruby 8 yeah totally dominating now and
looking at that f8 night news which
tried roopd 8 yeah final final try the
ideas that after rook takes d8 Queen III
check all of a sudden black has a
perpetual so please not that one Sonya
Rubinstein took that pawn king g8
interior already could have taken the
rukon d8 but he decided to do it a
little bit differently Jackie gave that
check Chang went for f6 in this position
yeah here nimzowitsch resigned after
King h8
just taking that rook and again black
has no check the Queen has no meaningful
square and white would win easily by
means of Queenie seven and probably
Rukia fate the computer already sees a
meteor but it's not necessary if you see
that you're completely winning you don't
need to calculate to made a very very
nice game by Rubenstein who showed how
to use a big space advantage if we go
back to look at a couple of key
situations here we see how that f4 break
was the right pawn even in this position
after the capture white had gained space
but still had total control over all the
critical central squares he could slowly
push forward this is important
repositioning your bishop and to the
best and possible diagonal and this is a
very very nice move white of course
would have had a better game also with
other continuations but taking on f6
this is really a high-class move that
shows that Rubinstein didn't play with
many ya predefined
the prep that prejudices and chess yeah
like we don't want to give that great
bishop of course the bishop is a
fantastic piece on b2 but what we do is
we carry the game forward and we make
progress this is even better than
enjoying that bishop on b2 here black's
pieces are completely killed and the
black queen is in a very very bad
situation this is a very important point
this some position can never be a I mean
even on the other circumstances black
wouldn't be in great shape but if you
imagine this position was let's say upon
f6 and the Queen back to d8
then it might be somewhat defensible but
here we see how badly blacks queuing is
positioned
it's almost trapped with g5b should be
to a very nice display by Rubenstein
also shows how patients can be rewarding
yeah just be patient and play moves like
this one yeah covering in foreign
squares there's no need to rush things I
hope you enjoyed this game in the middle
game series it really showed how to yeah
tighten the screws and sets in this kind
of strategic positional squeeze and then
at some moments a non-standard decision
can be very strong like Bishop takes f6
you hope you enjoyed that thanks for
watching